A Man Once Tried to Raise His Son as a Native
Speaker in Klingon
The man is computational linguist Dr. d’Armond
Speers.
Speers is actually not a huge Start Trek fan
himself.
Indeed many Klingon language enthusiasts aren’t,
contrary to popular belief.
They tend to be language lovers fascinated
by constructed languages, of which Klingon
is a relatively thriving one, hence why they
gravitate towards it.
Speers became fascinated with the Klingon
language after reading a flyer on a bulletin
board at Georgetown where Speers was studying
linguistics.
The flyer was advertising the Klingon Language
Institute (KLI), founded by Dr. Larence M.
Schoen.
“I thought to myself, ‘A new language.’
The fact that it was a constructed language
really appealed to me.
It sounded like fun,” said Speers.
He soon became one of the more famous members
of KLI when he decided to experiment with
trying to teach a child to be a native speaker
of Klingon, his own son, Alec.
Specifically, he stated, “I was interested
in the question of whether my son, going through
his first language acquisition process, would
acquire it like any human language.”
So as not to cause his Alec to have potential
learning disabilities and to make sure his
son could fully integrate into society without
language problems, Speers’ wife, who was
fully behind Speers’ experiment, always
spoke English to the child.
(The reason for concern was that lack of an
adequate language for your brain to use before
the age of around 5 can severely stunt a person’s
mental capacity and causes extremely detrimental
learning disabilities in later life, which
through history is largely why deaf people
were once considered mentally handicapped,
even though with an adequate language taught
to them at an early age, like a sign language,
they are just as smart as anyone else.
For more on this, checkout our article on
TodayIFoundOut.com: How Deaf People Think.)
In any event, unlike his wife, Speers almost
exclusively spoke to Alec in Klingon.
He even would sing the Klingon Imperial Anthem,
May the Empire Endure, as a bedtime lullaby
to Alec, which his son soon picked up and
would also sing.
This experiment went on for about three years,
during which time, as you might imagine, Speers
was given a lot of funny looks in public as
he’d converse with Alec in Klingon.
At first when people would ask what language
he was speaking, Speers would respond, “speaking
Klingon”, but after getting a lot of dirty
looks and comments for this, he switched to
just saying, “speaking a constructed language”,
which generally would forestall potential
negative comments.
Despite certain people being aghast that a
father would do this, thinking it perhaps
detrimental to a child, Speers, being a language
expert had a different view on it.
“My feeling is that it’s good for people
in general to know more than one language.
You get different viewpoints and perspectives
on things, and there is evidence to suggest
that kids who are bilingual do better academically,
whether their second language is a constructed
language or not.”
Despite the limitation of the language, Speers
claimed, “I’ve been able to say almost
everything I’ve needed to say to Alec in
Klingon…
One of the reasons I find the Klingon language
so interesting is that because the vocabulary
and grammar is so limited, you really have
to think to figure out how you’re going
to say something.”
For instance, “When I ask him to turn out
the lights, I say the Klingon for ‘make
it dark’.”
This joy found in the difficulty in saying
things in Klingon over English didn’t rub
off on his son, and Alec more and more resisted
speaking in Klingon, as Speers anticipated
in the beginning.
“There’s going to come a time when he’s
going to stop making the effort to speak Klingon
because it’ll be easier for him to speak
English.”
Further, Speers was the only person who would
speak this language to Alec and the boy never
saw Star Trek during this experiment, so didn’t
ever see anyone but his father speaking it.
As everyone else spoke English, Alec gradually
stopped responding to his father if he spoke
Klingon and, around three years old, Speers
states, “He stopped listening to me when
I spoke in Klingon.
It was clear that he didn’t enjoy it, and
I didn’t want to make it into a problem,
so I switched to English…”
Today the teenage Alec no longer is fluent
in Klingon and reportedly can’t even pick
out the meaning of individual words of the
language, which probably is a fact that helps
him out with the ladies in High School.
Bonus Facts:
• The Klingon language continues to grow,
despite the lack of new Star Trek shows or
movies featuring it, with new words added
each year, generally thought up by Marc Okrand,
the person who often mistakenly is said to
have first created the Klingon Language (in
fact, the actor who played “Scotty”, James
Doohan, did that at a very rudimentary level,
coming up with the style and the first few
words.
Okrand took James Doohan’s work and made
it into a full language, which is why he’s
generally given the credit for first coming
up with it, doing the vast majority of the
work to make it into a real language.)
• It is estimated that approximately 20-30
people in the world, including Speers, are
fluent speakers of Klingon, with another few
thousand that are familiar enough that they
can pick out words when they hear
it spoken.